Today friends, I am shooting from the
hip. That is I am teaching the magical
art of poi hip reels. I've labored for a
long time to find kind of a foolproof
lesson for getting these down. And I
will confess that I am still looking for
that lesson. But in the meantime, what I
can do is I can outline to you exactly
what a hip reel is in theory and how you
can perform it in a variety of different
ways. So we're going to drill into that
in this video.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we're going to
drill down what hip reels are and how
you can practice them. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Firemecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyoter, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel, Becca Beckon. Thank you so much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. So, there are a lot of PO
tricks that I have taught over the years
that I have great exercises that are
super intuitive and work for everybody
to get down a given trick. And hip
reels, to my great frustration, are not
one of them. See, I've taught a lot of
people hip reels over the years. And for
a very significant number of them,
there's just something that goes wrong
in trying to find this position right
here where you have your hand
articulated close to your hip like
you're performing chicken wings. A lot
of people will be in a place where they
just never find the articulation of the
wrist very comfortable. Others will try
and do the overhand rather than the
underhand tic tac. Yes, I will explain
what that is in this video. But I've
never really been able to come up with
an exercise that is foolproof and works
for everybody on this one. But what I
can do is I can outline an enormous
amount of theory from having tried to
teach this in a variety of different
ways. And hopefully it'll make something
click for you. So, first and foremost,
just the basics. When I refer to a hip
reel, what I'm talking about is
essentially a tic-tac. That is this poi
move where I'm taking the poi back and
forth across my body while I continue to
spin it in a given direction. There's
this nice little cross point as it goes
back and forth across these parallel
planes here where my hand is sitting and
where I could stick another body part,
including perhaps a hip. How about that?
So hip reels are really just the
application of this idea and placing it
in such a way that our hand is sitting
next to our hip and we're able to
perform a tic tac back and forth in
front of and behind the hip like so. But
doing that requires that we have to get
comfortable with doing a kind of strange
articulation of our hand and our wrist
that only works in this one spot. And to
understand what exactly this is, I'd
like to introduce you to what I refer to
as overhand and underhand tic tacs. Now,
if you have learned how to do tic tacs,
I can just about guarantee that the tic
tac that you learned is what I call the
overhand tic tac. You know it's the
overhand because if you're performing it
out here in wall plane, you're
inevitably going to find that the palm
of your hand is pointing forwards
towards the audience and your thumb is
pointing up towards the ceiling. There
are small variations where say you might
have your palm pointed down towards the
floor and your thumb towards the
audience or even your palm pointed
straight up towards the ceiling and your
thumb pointed back. All of these still
count as what I'm calling the overhand
tic tac. So it can look like this. It
can look like this. It can look like
this. But fundamentally all of these
involve performing the tic tac in such a
way that the point of control that you
have over the poi tether is always above
your wrist and elbow. So does that mean
that there is an underhand tic tac? Yes.
Yes, it does. In fact, the change in
articulation needs to be that rather
than say starting with your palm
pointing towards the audience, you turn
it around such that your palm is
pointing back away from the audience and
your thumb is pointing straight down.
This inevitably means that you have to
bring your elbow up a little bit and
you'll now find that your thumb is
always hanging out beneath your elbow
heightwise. Now, it can take a little
bit of work to get to a point where that
feels comfortable or intuitive. And for
some people, it never really feels
comfortable or intuitive. Um, but that
at least gives you a general idea of
where you want your starting point here
to be. Okay. So, in getting down the
difference between the overhand and the
underhand tic tac, I think the best way
to do that is to stretch out your arm as
far as you can out in wall plane away
from you and start by performing 10
overhand tic tacs. When you've completed
those 10, switch your wrist and elbow
around to perform 10 underhand tic tacs.
And please note, the direction the PO is
spinning in hasn't changed one bit. All
that's changed is where my palm and
thumb are pointing and what the
articulation of them is relative to my
elbow. Okay. So, next step, I want you
to go ahead and bend that elbow and
bring your hand beneath it. This is not
going to feel comfortable, but it is
helpful. Again, you want to try and get
in 10 tic tacs in this underhand
position here. Um, please note, a lot of
people will try and cheat and perform
the overhand. You know you're doing it
right if your elbow is clear of your
body. If your elbow is touching the side
of you, you're doing the overhand. If
the elbow is cocked out away from you,
that's the underhand. So once you've
gotten in 10 tic tacs right here, you're
going to go ahead and pull in your hand
next to your hip. And voila, what do you
know? That is the underhand tic tac. And
thus a hip reel. You are now performing
that tic tac around your hip.
Congratulations. And if you need just a
little bit of detail on what's actually
going on here with the poi, I can help
you out. We're going to pantoime what
it's doing with just my index finger.
Here's how. We're going to start off
with my arm pointed out to the side. And
I'm going to imagine that I'm kind of
finger painting straight down to a point
next to my hip. When I do that, I am now
bringing my finger to point out towards
the opposite hip. And I'm going to go
ahead and turn my upper body just
slightly as my finger points up. And
then it's going to point back behind me
and finger paint back out. Once again, I
finger paint down around to my hip. I
let my finger come around in a little
circle behind my back and then come back
out. Here's what that looks like from
the front. I finger paint down. Bring my
finger around in a uh circle behind my
hip and then come back out. Behind,
around, come back out. Behind, around,
come back out from the side. Behind,
come back out. Like so. We can then go
ahead and get the poi involved by
hooking our index finger underneath the
tether. And think that we're going to
bring it down and around under our hip
and back out. down and around under our
hip and then back out like so. We're
still doing the little finger painting
move. We're just making the poi kind of
an extension of what the index finger is
doing here. Going around in that little
circle behind the hip and then coming
back out to either side. All right. So
once that is feeling a little bit more
comfortable, what you're going to want
to do is work on getting down your hip
reels both with the PO spinning
clockwise as well as
counterclockwise around your hip. Each
hand usually has a direction that feels
a little bit more comfortable than the
other. But you should practice with both
hands. So with the right hand, both
clockwise and counterclockwise. And then
with the left hand, both
counterclockwise as well as clockwise
like so. And once you get that down with
both hands, it's time to start working
with the two of them together. So I
would start off in together same. And
you can kind of uh get more comfortable
and and uh work your way into this
slowly by performing 10 hip reels with
just one hand at a time. say starting
with your right and then performing 10
hip reels with just your left while the
other hand just kind of sits in front of
you spinning in wall plane and then you
practice doing the hip reel with both
hands at the same time. And look at
that, you got your hip reels down in
together same. You want to learn how to
do this both clockwise as well as
counterclockwise in together same. Now
we can also apply these techniques to
working in together opposites as well.
I'm working with an inward butterfly
here. And I'll first perform 10 hip
reels with just my right hand. Going
back and forth, back and forth with that
tic-tac next to my right hip. Make sure
your elbow is out away from you. Again,
if your elbow is closer to the side of
your body than your uh hand is, then
you're doing the overhand. Make sure
they're either the same distance or your
elbows a little bit further away from
you as you're doing this. And then work
to do 10 of these underhand tic tacs
with your left hand going back and forth
here. And then work on doing them both
at the same time. And of course, when
you're working with together opposites,
you also have the great option of being
able to alternate them back and forth.
So I can do right behind, left behind,
right behind, left behind, like so, and
create a nice groovy poi move in the
process. Then we want to do the same
thing with the po spinning in an outward
butterfly. Again, give me 10 tic tacs
with just your right hand and then 10
tic tacs with just your left hand. And
then you can do them both
together. And you can alternate them
back and forth, which this one I think
looks pretty cool if I do say so myself.
Now, I haven't yet really found a clean
way to do hip reels and split opposites,
but in split time, same direction, we
can get a watermill out of this. Here's
how. We start off with the PO spinning
split time same direction uh out here in
wall plane. And you want to use your
lanes of poi in order to make sure the
PO don't run into each other as you're
spinning them here. I'll include a link
to a tutorial on how to get down the
lanes of poi up in the cards. And once
again, you perform 10 tic tacs with your
right hand, then 10 tacs with your left
hand. And rather than doing that thing
where we try and do both of them at the
same time, I highly recommend just
alternating them right, left, right,
left, right, left to get that lovely
watermel. And of course, we can reverse
direction here to counterclockwise. Do
10 tic tacs with just the right hand. Do
10 tic tacs with just the left hand. And
alternate back and forth between them.
Fantastic. So, I hope that that is a
helpful overview of kind of the theory
behind hip reels and some of the
techniques that you can perform with
them. If you'd like to get deeper into
the world of tic tacs and both hip reels
and shoulder reels, I have been doing a
ton of work with them on the flow circle
over on my Patreon. I will go ahead and
leave a link to that down in the
description as well as up in the cards
so you can go check it out. But in the
meantime, if you got anything out of
this video, please leave a like,
comment, share, and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel
grow. This video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I'd love to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you
all so much. You rock. If you enjoy the
content that I produce, these lessons,
these videos, these tutorials, and you
want to help out the channel, I would
really appreciate it. Here's a few ways
that you can do it. Number one, you can
get your name in the credits or access
to a host of other rewards by signing up
for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. Link in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Uh, if on the other hand, you are sick
of all of the subscription services out
there, and hey, we've all been there,
you can just send me a one-off donation
via either Venmo or PayPal. Uh, I am
Drexfactor on both platforms, and I will
leave a link to donations for those two
platforms down in the description. Uh,
either way, thank you so much for your
support. And if you'd like to learn
about some other applications for hip
reels, namely their application for tuck
turns, I will go ahead and leave a link
to a tutorial on how to perform those
tuck turns down in the description as
well as up here on screen. Thank you so
much for watching. Make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care now.
Peace.